AND CALL THIS. HEARING OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
ORDER THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER OBVIOUSLY GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME TO ANOTHER SHORT
HEARING ON THE PROPOSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
RESPONSE. TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TONIGHT
HERE TO A SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITHTHOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY. WHICH IS A GOOD THING.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE SOCIAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE.
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER%
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR MINUTES SAY THAT
AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE. SIX FOUR. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FOUR
FIVE. SHOULD MAKES ME. SIX FIVE
FOUR. TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN LET
ME SAY THAT AGAIN. SIX FIVE
FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THE WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
NOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THE TOP AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING HER TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR THE PATIENCE SO PLEASE
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO TALK. TURN
OFF THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON SO WE CAN HEAR
YOU PROPERLY. OBVIOUSLY ALL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. DISRUPTIVE
WHICH MAY MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTATES
SO OBVIOUSLY THE COR MATTERS.
AND PATIENCE IS IMPORTANT. IT'S
ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REMIND
EVERYONE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
THAT THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE.
SO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY
TO THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL. YOU ARE NOT TESTED BY
YOUR TESTIFYING ON. PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY OR RE LITIGATING THE
POLICY MERITS OF THE BILL
BECAUSE I USE THOSE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DONE IN POLICY
COMMITTEE. WHILE EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS.
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE ONE BILL TODAY
ON THE AGENDA AND THAT'S SB
SEVEN FIVE SENATE PRO TEM
ATKINS BEFORE WE ARE PRESENTED
WITH THE BILL LET'S ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM MR SECRETARY COULD
YOU PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PORTANTINO I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE BATES YEAH
BATES HERE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
HERE JONES. JONES HERE LAYERED
HERE LAYERED HERE BY COUNTY
SHERIFF'S CASKEY HERE REPORTER.
WE HAVE A FARM OKAY SO MISTER
MCGUIRE I BELIEVE YOU'RE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF THE PRO
TEM PLEASE STEP FORWARD AND
TELL US ABOUT SB SEVEN- THE
JOBS AND ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT
THROUGH ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE MORNING AT MISTER
CHAIR AND FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR FOR HIS- DIRECT
ENGAGEMENT ALWAYS ON
LEGISLATION IN SPECIFICALLY ON
THIS ISSUE INTO YOUR VERY
CAPABLE STAFF TEAM. SB SEVEN IS
THE PERFECT AMERICANS BILL THAT
WILL ADDRESS OUR STATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS AND
HELP GET CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
MOVING AGAIN FROM THIS COVERT
INDUCED RECESSION THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION NEXT BIG STAINS AND
EXPANDS PROVISIONS OF A
SEQUENCE STREAMLINING STATUTE
KNOWN AS AB NINE HUNDRED. WHICH
REDUCE PAPERWORK- AN EXPEDITED
LEGAL CHALLENGES TO LARGE MULTI
BENEFIT HOUSING GREEN ENERGY AS
WELL AS MANUFACTURING PROJECTS
NOW SB SEVEN EXTENDS TO TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE SUNSET OF
AB NINE HUNDRED THROUGH THE END
OF THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
FOR THE LARGER PROJECTS COVERED
UNDER THE PRIOR LAW BUT THIS
BILL EXPANDS THE LAW TO APPLY
STREAMLINING TO MUCH SMALLER
HOUSING PROJECTS LOWERING THE
THRESHOLD OF QUALIFYING
PROJECTS TO FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S AN 85% REDUCTION
IN 85% REDUCTION REQUIRED
INVESTMENT. UNDER THE PRIOR LAW
UNDER SB SEVEN HOUSING PROJECTS
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE AT LEAST
15% AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO BE
INFILL BUT THEY ALSO NEED TO
HAVE SKILLED ENTRY AND LABOR
REQUIREMENTS. AN ELEVATED
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS NOW
THIS BILL MAY SEEM FAMILIAR TO
THE CHAIR AND TO THE COMMITTEE-
IT IS VERY MUCH SIMILAR TO SB
NINE NINETY FIVE- THAT WAS
PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE ON A BIPARTISAN VOTE.
NINE NINETY FIVE ALSO PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY WITH OVER SIXTY
VOTES FOR IMPORTS THE FAILED TO
RETURN TO THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE VOTE BEFORE SESSION
EXPIRED LAST AUGUST. MISTER
CHAIR YOUR FISCAL ANALYSIS TO A
NOTE THAT ANY STATE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROCESSING
APPLICANTS UNDER SB SEVEN MAY
BE RECOVERED IN FEES CHARGED BY
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH. SB. SIX SEVEN IS
SUPPORTED BY GOOD GO MAYOR SAM-
HOUSING DEVELOPERS THROUGH. THE
STATE FROM SAN DIEGO TO THE
AREA- INTO DAY AT MISTER CHAIR
WE'VE KEN WELCH WHO IS THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OFFICER IN
THE CITY SAN JOSE PREPARED TO
TESTIFY. ALONG WITH RON MILLER
BERNIE REPRESENTING THE A TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR ATKINS RESEARCHER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THIS THANK YOU MISTER
MCGUIRE. AND THANK YOU FOR
POINTING OUT OUR TO- WITNESSES-
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
WE ARE. OBVIOUSLY DO HE TO ALL
KINDS OF CONSTRAINTS. WE LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WHAT YOU HAVE AND
THEN THE OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
LINE WILL BE LIMITED TO THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION. AND- WITH THAT
THE- EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR WE
HAVE OUR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
TEED UP IF THEY COULD CONFINE
THEIR COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES
EACH. THAT WOULD BE THE LIMIT
AND WE WILL LOOK FOR THEIR ANY
OPPOSITION THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES THE SAME THREE
MINUTES SO IF YOU COULD LINE UP
PART TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
OF OUR WITNESSES COULD CONFINE
THEMSELVES THE THREE MINUTES
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. THERE. I'M
I'M KIM WALLACE THE FIRST
WITNESS WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
START SPEAKING YES I WOULD
THANK YOU. YEAH OKAY GREAT GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE AND KIM
WALLACE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
DIRECTOR AND DEPUTY CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE. I'D LIKE TO THANK
CHAIRPERSON PORTANTINO AND
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE.
FOR TAKING UP SENATE BILL SEVEN
EARLY IN THE SESSION I ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THOSE OF YOU WHO
SUPPORTED AT EIGHT NINE NINE
FIVE LAST YEAR. AND SPECIAL
THANK YOU TO PRO TEM ATKINS FOR
HER AUTHORSHIP OF THIS
LEGISLATION. MOVING FORWARD
EXPEDITIOUSLY THIS YEAR WITH
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. AND PER
LONGSTANDING LEADERSHIP FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. MY SATURDAY
AND SEVERAL OTHER CITIES HAD
CERTIFIED AB NINE HUNDRED
PROJECTS THAT WERE
UNDERSTANDABLY THE LATE BY THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC. IN SAN
JOSE GOOGLE'S DOWNTOWN WEST
PROJECT COMPRISES ONE OF THE
MOST IMPACTFUL AND BROADLY
BENEFICIAL PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR CITY IF NOT IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS PROJECT IN PROJECTS LIKE
IT CONFRONT CALIFORNIA'S
MULTIPLE CRISIS ARGUED WITH
REAL SOLUTIONS AND THEY ALL
HAVE IMPORTANT FISCAL ELEMENTS
TO THEM. THE HELP CONFRONT OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS THE
DOWNTOWN WEST PROJECT WILL
PRODUCE MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND
HIGH DENSITY HOMES. AT LEAST
25% OF WHICH WILL BE RENT
RESTRICTED AND AFFORDABLE. HOW
CAN FIND OUR JOB CRISIS AT A
TIME WHERE WE FACED 9%
UNEMPLOYMENT STATEWIDE
CONSTRUCTING THESE KIND OF
URBAN VILLAGE DEVELOPMENT WITH
MORE THAN SEVEN MILLION SQUARE
FEET OF OFFICE RETAIL HOTEL
RESTAURANTS AND HOMES. WILL
PRODUCE. FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED PREVAILING WAGE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND OF COURSE
GOOGLE WILL LONGER TERM
EMPLOYMENT WILL GENERATE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE PROJECT ALSO
CLEARLY CAN OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
WHICH HAS JUST GOAL ASPECTS TO
IT THAT WILL MAXIMIZE. AT THE
HIGHEST POSSIBLE DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT AROUND CANDIDATES
DOWNTOWN CENTRAL STATION WHICH
IS A MAJOR PLACE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WERE ALL OF THE
TRANSIT SYSTEM AND BIRDS. AND
FINALLY WE KNOW THE PANDEMIC
HAS EXACERBATED AND HIGHLIGHTED
CALIFORNIA'S STARK ECONOMIC
DIVIDE. DOWNTOWN WEST PROJECT
AND PROJECTS LIKE IT WILL
GENERATE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN COMMUNITY
BENEFITS FOR ANTI DISPLACEMENT
EFFORTS AND FOR JOB TRAINING
EDUCATION AND HOME AFFILIATION
FOR OUR MOST MARGINALIZED
POPULATIONS. BODY'S APPROVAL
AND SUPPORT OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE GOVERNOR. WE INTEND TO
BRING THE DOWNTOWN WEST PROJECT
FOR MY CITY COUNCIL APPROVAL IN
MAY. WELL HAVE PARTIAL
TRANSCRIPT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT
AND SHOVELS IN THE GROUND
SHORTLY THERE AFTER. THERE
COULD NOT BE A MORE NEEDED TIME
FOR THIS KIND OF TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENT TO BE MADE IN OUR
CITY AND IN OUR CALIFORNIA IT'S
A KEY PART OF THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND THE FISCAL HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND OUR
STATE. I DEEPLY APPRECIATE- TO
WHATEVER EXTENT YOU'RE ABLE TO
SHARE OUR SENSE OF URGENCY AND
IMPORTANCE FOR THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS HISTORIC AND DEEPLY
CHALLENGING MOMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE A MR MILLER FROM THE LA
ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
AS WELL MR MILLER. THIS IS.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING-
CHAIRMAN PORTANTINO AND MEMBERS
OF THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
I'M RON MILLER EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE AILING ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE WHOLE
STATE BUILDING TRADES OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND APPRENTICES.
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S WITHIN
HUNDREDS OF LOCAL UNIONS AND
DISTRICT COUNCILS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN. I COULD TALK TO YOU
ABOUT ALL THE GOOD THINGS IT
DOES FOR WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION TRADES. BUT I
THINK MOST OF YOU KNOW ALL OF
THOSE BENEFITS. THIS BILL WOULD
REAUTHORIZE AND EXTEND THE JOBS
AND ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT
THROUGH ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. WHICH IS LED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEARLY TWENTY
PROJECTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. AND MANY OF WHICH
INCLUDED A HOUSING COMPONENT.
WHILE PROVIDING WORK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOUSANDS OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. WITH THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES IN
PLACE IN CITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE IT TAKES FOREVER TO GET
PROJECTS ENTITLED AND READY NEW
CONSTRUCTION. WITH THAT BEING
SAID WE HAVE QUITE A FEW
PROJECTS THAT ARE IN NEED OF
THIS BILL. TO GET PASSED TO
CONTINUE THEIR ENTITLEMENT
PROCESS. WE HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WERE THE WORK AND IN
LOS ANGELES PROPER THERE IS
RELYING ON PASSAGE OF THIS BILL.
THEN WITH THE CURRENT COVERED
PANDEMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION AS WE KNOW IT HAS
BEEN DECIMATED. AND IT HAD A
DIRECT EFFECT ON THE ECONOMY UP
AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT THAT WE ALREADY
DIDN'T HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BUT THE
CRISIS IS GETTING MUCH MUCH
WORSE. THAN THE PROJECTS IN THE
QUEUE AND FUTURE PROJECTS THAT
ARE PROPOSED WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CONTRIBUTE RELIEF.
TO THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS AND AT THE SAME TIME
BOOST THE ECONOMY AND GET THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BACK TO
WORK. YOU KNOW WE WE'RE WORKING
WITH- JUDGE CARTER IN LA.
HAVING MEETINGS WITH HIM- THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IS VERY
REAL HERE IN LOS ANGELES. AND
THE WAY TO GET OUT OF THAT IS
TO BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND SO WHEN WE GET THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BACK TO
WORK. WE HAVE ALL LEARNED THAT
WHEN CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
THRIVES THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THRIVES. WIRED
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
MOVE AONG FOR PASSAGE QUICKLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MILLER- THAT CONCLUDES THE
TESTIMONY OF OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO- THIS ROOM. TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WANTS TO ADD
A- ME TOO SO AGAIN YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES. WE STAND PROUDLY
ALONGSIDE THE BUILDING TRADES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE IN ONE TWELVE WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN.
AND SO NOW WE WILL GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAITING
ON THE- CONFERENCE LINES AND SO
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE VISUALS AND AGAIN.
WE'RE JUST TAKING YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION- SO MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD START OUR FOLKS ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISTER PROGRAM FOR
CLARIFICATION AT THIS POINT
WE'RE UNABLE TO DISCERN IF
THEY'RE IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. SO WE'LL JUST HAVE
TO GO TO THE PUBLIC IN GENERAL
MY APOLOGIES OKAY HOW MANY DO
WE HAVE ON THE LINE- ONE
TWENTY. HERE NEAR THIRTY HIP
TWENTY EIGHT IS A GOOD NUMBER
OKAY SO EVERYBODY THEY CAN ALL
HEAR ME SO HE COULD CONFINE
YOURSELF TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
WILL JUST START TAKING THEM ONE
AT A TIME AND THEN WE'LL GO
BACK TO SEE IF THERE'S A
PRIMARY. OPPOSE BUT I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION SO
LET'S JUST GO THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE LIST. THANK YOU
LINE TEN EURO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE THEY'RE ALL. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JOHN ROCK KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
GOOGLE AND SUPPORT. BOB WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE ELEVEN LINE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR SURE
NUMBERS CAN BE DONE HIT AROUND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABOR'S SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY LINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A LINE
FIFTEEN DO YOU HAVE A STATEMENT.
WHAT MOVEON BLAME SIXTEEN ONE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
LINE SIXTEEN DO YOU HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SHARE. WILL
MOVE ONLINE SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHARLES
RIGHT ON BEHALF OF SUNSET AND
WILCOX IN HOLLYWOOD CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST. THANK
YOU LINE EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STILL DEAL
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT IF YOU. WELL NEXT IN
LINE TWENTY FOUR TWO FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MANY CANAL- CEO MODERATE
THANK THIS COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
SUPPORTED SB SEVEN AND STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
WELCOME LINE TWENTY SIX TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MATTHEW GAINES REPRESENT
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
NUMBER TWELVE AND WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORTER THAT'S EAST OF
THEM ALONG WITH THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
WELCOME LINE TWENTY SEVEN TWO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WARNING THIS IS COLIN JOHNSON
WITH- BRICKLAYERS NOW I CRASHED
LOCAL THREE OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT. AT. SEVEN WELCOME LINE
TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RESEARCH HERE MEMBERS
MIKE MONAHAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. ESTHER
STATE COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
ATKINS SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR COMMENT FROM
LINE THIRTY ONE THREE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN IT'S TIME TO BE SANYA
WITH THE CEMENT MASONS LOCAL
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN THANK YOU. WELCOME
LINE THIRTY TWO THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS THAT THE OPENS THE
CARPENTERS UNION LOCAL TWO
SEVENTEEN REPRESENTS AMATIL
COUNTY. OUR MEMBERSHIP IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
SEVEN AND WE URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
MISTER GERRY SWEENEY WITH
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT FIVE
THREE AM LAYERED STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN. NEXT WE'LL CLIMB
THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN. HE'S
THIRTY SEVEN. THIRTY SEVEN
AIRLINERS OKAY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT KREMIN T.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
THAT A CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT. THANK YOU.
WELCOME I AM THIRTY FOUR THREE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS TIMOTHY RICE AGAIN I
REPRESENT CARPENTERS LOCAL
TWENTY TWO IN SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT IN WE SHOULD I VOTE.
THANK YOU. WELCOME LINE THIRTY
NINE THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JIM ELROD I'M THE BUSINESS
MANAGER FINANCIAL SECRETARY FOR
IBEW LOCAL FOUR TO EIGHT AND WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
GRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THANK YOU. WHAT A LINE
FOR ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
RYAN LYING WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS LOCAL EIGHT- WE
REPRESENT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
THREE FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
NOT GOING TO WIN YOUR HOST I
WOULD CARPENTERS LOCAL SEVEN
THIRTEEN WHICH COVERS ALL THE
MAJOR COUNTY I'M CALLING IN
THIS MORNING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN INTERDIGITAL PORTED
AS WELL AND BOTH A ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. WE'RE THE LINE
FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO HI THIS IS
MITCHELL BATTLE OF THE IRON
WORKERS LOCAL ONE ATM
SACRAMENTO WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT ABOUT THE SEVEN. THANK
YOU. WELCOME LINE THIRTY SIX
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS JOHN SPAULDING I
REPRESENT THE CURTAINS INYO AND
MONO COUNTIES BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES OF SB SEVEN. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS DAVID
BEANIE REPRESENTING THE SANTA
CLARA AND SAN BENITO COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES FOR SB SEVEN.
CONNECTS TO LINE FORTY NINE
FOUR NINE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS RICK SALAS CALLING FROM
CARPENTERS LOCAL FLORAL FIVE
REPRESENTING SANTA CLARA AND
SAN BENITO COUNTIES AND WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. SEVEN AND URGENT I VOTE.
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE FIFTY
ONE FIVE ONE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
HOLD YOUR LINE MOMENTARILY.
FIVE ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT
WE'RE JOINED WITH STATE
BUILDING TRADES STRONG
SUPPORTER SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
PINE FIFTY THREE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.ONE FIFTY
THREE DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT TO
SHARE. HELLO YES BUT YOU OKAY
GIVE ME A NUMBER ARE YOU BILL
TRAM WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL WE ARE AT SUPPORT FOR
AT LEAST SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE SAMA.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE OF THE ONE
MOMENT FIFTY FIVE. FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE GREAT
GARDENING WITH INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
LOCAL EIGHT AND WE'RE JOINING
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN. HE. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
ONE SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
BRETT DAVIS WITH DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN LOCAL UNION
SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE WITH
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE ARE JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE. SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MANY LAME GONZALEZ THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN LOCAL
FORTY SEVEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES AND WE'RE ARE JOINING
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES WITH
THEIR STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT.
SEVEN. THANK YOU MR HERE TO THE
BEST OF Y ABILITY. ALL THE
LINES THAT HAVE DIALED IN TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SHARE THEIR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION- SEEING NO ONE I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
PRIMARY SPEAKERS ON THE LINE
AND THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. OPPOSED I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. THAT
IS SUPPOSE THAT WNTS TO SPEAK.
MISTER MODERATOR WILL CHECK THE
LINE ONE LAST TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S NOBODY ONLINE WHO
WANTS TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A LINE
IT'S LINE TWENTY EIGHT I
BELIEVE IT MAY BE IN SUPPORT.
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THAT WILL BE OUR FINAL SPEAKER.
YES THANK YOU MY NAME IS MARK
YOUR BILL I REPRESENT MEMBERS
OF THE HEATING PROCESS LEADERS
LOCAL SIXTEEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE JOIN THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN IS WRITTEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIR I MOVED THE BILL WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL- THERE'S
NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENT- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- MY
UNDERSTAND IS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. AND WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING- WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS I
KNOW MR WHITE HOUSE YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. YES I'D I'D I WOULD-
I HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT THE
FISCAL IMPACT ON THE STATE WE
KNOW THAT. THAT THE COURTS HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY PUBLIC JUST
LIKE WE'VE JUST HEARD TESTIMONY
ON THE MERITS OF THIS BILL ON
THE FROM THE BUILDING TRADES
BUT WE KNOW THAT THE COURTS
HAVE. COURTS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
WE JUST HAD A FOUR HOUR HEARING
ON TUESDAY SENATOR LAYERED AND
JOINT AND JONES JOIN ME ON
THERE'S BEEN NO MOVEMENT ON
CIVIL LITIGATION. SO THAT'S ALL
BACKED UP WE KNOW THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN THE WE'VE DELAYED THE
ACTIONS ON THE VACATIONS AND
MONEY JUDGMENTS WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S ALL BACKED UP TO THE
COURTS. IN THIS TO REFRESH
EVERYBODY'S MEMORY WE CUT THE
COURTS BUDGET BY 10% LAST YEAR
SO WE HAVE LESS MONEY AND
THEY'RE DEALING WITH COOPERATE
SO. I KNOW IT'S NOT NOTHING HI
WE ARE AND I KNOW I REALIZE
WHAT'S THE CONCERN THE IMPACT
OF THE COURTS IS THAT THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON. AB
NINE HUNDRED WHICH INCIDENTALLY
I DID VOTE FOR BUCHANAN'S BILL
WITH A- YEARS AGO BUT SOME
OTHER MEMBERS ON HERE HE SAID
IT'S GOING TO HAVE SOME IMPACT.
AND THEY'RE ALREADY BEHIND ON
THE ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE
WHAT THE- THE THIRD BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT SO. I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
HERE AND ESTIMATES. BUT WE KNOW
WE'VE HEARD. TESTIMONY ON THE
MAY. OF THESE. PROJECTS IN THE
PIPE AND WE'RE GOING TO. THE
HUNDRED MILLION AND REDUCE IT
TO FIFTEEN MILLION SO THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE PEOPLE THAT
ARE GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE. I
ASSUME THE PEOPLE WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE- EXIT
EXPEDITED- PERMITTING. BUT THAT
HAS AN IMPACT ON THE COURTS AND
THE COURTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GIVE US SOME ESTIMATE. ON WHAT
LOOKING INTO THE CRYSTAL BALL
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN TO HIM. PLUS OVER
LATE WITH THE DELAYS THAT WE'VE
HAD ON THE ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE JUST IN GENERALLY IN
THE COURTS. BECAUSE THESE
FACILITIES ARE NOT. CONSTRUCTED
TO DEAL WITH COBIT N. STREET
SOCIAL DISTANCING SO. I WOULD
ASK IF THE- IF WE COULD IF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SAYS
WITH THE FISCAL COMMITTEE COULD
GET SOME INFORMATION FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. FOR FINANCE
ON WHAT THE ESTIMATE IS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT ZERO OR WHATEVER IT IS
JUST. LET US KNOW THAT'S MY
POINT. REVERB YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
ANALYSIS ALSO TALKS ABOUT- A
PROTRACTED LEGAL FIGHT HAVING.
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AND YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THERE'S CONFLICTING
OPINION ABOUT WHETHER THE
SHORTENED CYCLE WILL WILL
IMPACT GREATER THAN THE LONG
CYCLE BUSINESS WIRE YOU WANT TO
TACKLE THAT ARE- TO FORGET THAT
YOU WANT TO DO IT YEAH I DON'T
THINK YOU SO MUCH THANKS. SO
THEY LOOK AT IT THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED- AS THIS BILL
HAS BEEN ADVANCED. THE THIS
BILL IS A NINETY TO TAKE THE
ORIGINAL DEFINITION OF THE
ISSUE OF DAYS- SO IN PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS BILL IT WAS
BASED OFF OF CALENDAR DAYS.
RIGHT NOW IN THIS ITERATION OF
SB SEVEN IT'S JUST STATING DAYS
NOT BUSINESS DAYS NOT CALENDAR
DAYS WHICH PROVIDES THE COURTS
MORE FLEXIBILITY. ON THAT ISSUE
BUT AS FAR AS THE FISCAL WE'D
BE HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH A CENTER Y. CASKEY- ON
THAT ISSUE IN AS STATED- IN THE
ANALYSIS. FOR CARB AT EIGHT
HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
ANNUALLY WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT WOULD AT LEAST. BE RECOUP
THROUGH FEES- BUT AT BE HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH CERTAINLY
CASKEY DIRECTLY IN THE CITY. IF
HE'S ON THE CLARITY OF NINE
NINE FIVE DID DID CLARIFY WHAT
THE DAYS WERE IN THAT WHAT DO
YOU LIKE IT OR NOT BUT NOW THE
COURTS ARE SPLIT SO THAT ADDS
ANOTHER LAYER OF A FISCAL
IMPACT ON THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO DECIDE. WHAT WE GET
TO CHOOSE BUSINESSES WE'RE
GOING TO CHOOSE THOSE DAYS
THERE WAS. I MEAN SOMEBODY WAS
GOING TO GET. THE LIKE IT BUT
WAS THE IT WAS THE- THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE TO THE COURTS BE.
IF THE AND- IS THEY'RE GOING TO
RECEIVE ALL THESE FAST TRACK.
APPLICATIONS THAT PEOPLE CAN'T
GET TOGETHER THEN THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT OUR CONCERNS WERE SUPPOSED
TO FROM THE ARTS PROPERLY AND
WE HAVE A WE HAVE COMPETING
INTERESTS. THAT IS I KNOW THAT
THESE PROJECTS TO JUMP THE LINE
BUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THAT FISCAL IMPACT IS WORK WITH
WITH THE ANTICIPATION. IS
ELEGANT I DON'T EVER WANT TO
SPEAK FOR THE COURT'S
WHATSOEVER AT THAT IS NOT MY
ROLE HERE TODAY BUT WHAT I WILL
SAY. IS THIS DOES PROVIDE THEM
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY THEY CAN
BE ABLE TO DEFINE THE DAY'S
BUSINESS. VERSUS CALENDAR- IN
THIS IS WHAT THE FIRST VERSION
OF NINE NINE FIVE ACTUALLY HAD
IT WAS QUITE GENERIC THAT GAVE
THE COURTS. MORE AUTHORITY TO
BE TO DECIDE WHAT THOSE DAYS
ARE CALENDAR VERSUS BUSINESS AT
SO DOES PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY. I WILL ALSO SAY
THIS BOOK WE ALL KNOWN ISSUE OF
HOUSING WE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
GET THESE PROJECTS MOVED RIGHT.
WE ARE IN A CRISIS IN THE STATE
WE NEED ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
AFFORDABLE UNITS BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE-
AND THIS WILL HELP GET HOUSING
BUILT. FOR WORKING FAMILIES SO
WE'D BE HAPPY TO WORK DIRECTLY
WITH- CINEMA CASKEY BRINGS UP A
GOOD POINT AND- YOU HAVE- THE
COMMITMENT THAT I WILL FOLLOW
UP. AND THAT IS THAT YOUR
CLOTHES MISTER BARR THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR- FOR THE
ABILITY TO PRESENT IN THANK YOU
SO MUCH ASKING MEMBERS. THANK
YOU- WE ARE I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION
JUST ONE FINAL COMMENT
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE BUDGET THE DISCUSSION SO
OBVIOUSLY COURT FUNDING IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEING
DISCUSSED. THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS THE CIVIL COURT PIECE I
KNOW ALL I'VE HAD SEVERAL
MEETINGS ON AND- I DISCOURAGE
OBVIOUSLY THE- MISTER
REQUIREMENTS TO OUR CASKET TALK
OFF LINE AND WORK THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND THOSE
CONCERNS. WITH THAT MR
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER LEHRER. AND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE. FLOOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON F.
SIX. BY SENATOR AT. MO IS DEEP.
TO THE FLOOR. CENTER PORTENT. I
WOULD. AYE BATES. BATES I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI JONES.
JONES ARE LAYERED. LAYERED BY
MARK OWSKI HI. CASKEY I HAVE
SIX VOTES. IT IS SIX. ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT- THAT IS OUR- ONLY
BILL TODAY THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND PARTICIPATING IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE THEY WILL BE.
ADDED TO THE RECORD- WHICH
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
APPRECIATION. THANK EVERYONE
THIS. COMMITTEE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.